many Americans struggled to pay rising
health insurance premiums a CBS News
investigation has uncovered a scheme
that could make those premiums go even
higher rural hospitals are being
exploited by some healthcare executives
they are using them to make up 10 times
more from insurance companies this
raises costs for insurers who may then
pass the increase along to consumers Jim
Axelrod has more from our continuing
investigation Jim good morning good
morning we told you yesterday about a
South Florida lab owner billing drug
test through rural hospitals to take
advantage of their higher insurance
reimbursement rates well it turns out
he's not the only one engaging in this
questionable practice it's the state of
the art Jorge Perez is CEO of empower
group a Miami based health care company
that claims to specialize in rescuing
rural hospitals currently we have 16
facilities and we manage three more and
many of these hospitals were hospitals
that were in distressed it seems to me
to be a very challenging space rural
hospitals correct so why mess with it
because why not here's another reason to
help keep them in business insurance
companies reimburse rural hospitals for
lab testing at much higher rates
sometimes ten times more than they would
pay if the tests were run at an
independent lab it's mind-boggling to
think about all of the money that's been
made through this
Michelle Jordan is a lawyer who
represents campbellton graceful rural
hospital in Florida that's now closed
she says after Perez came in to manage
it he signed contracts with dozens of
labs across the country to send their
testing and their billing through
campbellton graceful the first to sign
up was Aaron Doral who owns reliance
labs in Sunrise Florida an accident can
change a life not only today but forever
he's also a personal injury lawyer why
was reliance a lab located in South
Florida sending samples all the way to
this community in the Florida Panhandle
I was told that they had so much work
that they needed to basically outsource
what's the real reason so that they
could utilize human graceful hospitals
reimbursement rates these are the
original patient records those
reimbursement rates made Perez in the
labs millions Jordan showed us the
records that were used to build lab
tests through the hospital alliances all
over here yeah they were paid about 67
million from our Hospital these records
sixty-seven million dollars for his part
George Perez denied signing the contract
with reliance or any other lab no this
is all forged that says George Perez
owner no by the way that's not even my
signature I'd love to get a copy of all
this I have no idea I was never the
owner you can check with the state
records
it's all federal you never made any kind
of arrangement with labs no so in the
hospitals you're running managing now
this practice doesn't no longer takes
place well there's nothing about no
longer I don't do it I don't practice
that kind of you know the management
that we put in it's not like that you
know we bring in other types of clinical
services which is why we were surprised
after that interview when we traveled to
South Florida hoping to speak with the
owner of Reliance labs Aaron too raw who
did we see standing together in front of
the lab Aaron Doral and George Perez
well he didn't speak with us that day in
an email Aaron Doral told us all testing
at the rural hospitals you mentioned is
properly built last month
BlueCross BlueShield kicked for oklahoma
hospitals Jorge Perez co-owns out of the
network
citing quote questionable billing for
lab programs so Jim you just happen to
get the two of them together you thought
so to shoot and they're both there
together
totally random yeah we want to talk to
mr. Durrell we rolled up taking some
pictures and who walks out of the front
of the lab
to enjoy forever that's Georgia's saying
I know nothing about nothing at one
point he did look at the camera like is
the camera still here how long you
staying the some days it's better to be
lucky than good yeah Jim Axelrod
a lot of good questions there